[موسيقى]
حبيت هوايه تجميع السيارات من الصغر يعني
كنت
زمان وانا صغير سيدي
سالني شو بدك قلت له بدي سياره حقيقيه بيت
انام العب فيها يعني من يومتها ضليت احب
السيارات القديمه
وبلشت يعني احاول انقذ السيارات القديمه
وين ما اشوف سياره قديمه مهجوره اظل
متابعها احاول انقذها ارجع التاريخ تبعها
كل سياره الها يعني عندي قصه الى حكايه
كيف بحكوا زي روحي يعني ما بقدر استغني
عنها بعيد الذكريات ما له ماضي ما له حاضر
بتذكر الاباء الاجداد جيران الناس الكبار
يعني تاريخ تاريخ
[موسيقى]
طبعا ساره سراحه الكلاسيك القديمه سيارات
مكلفه جدا عده اسباب اولا لانه عدم تواجد
القطعه
ببلادنا يعني معظم بدنا نضطر نطلع على
الاردن على سوريا نوصي من برا للتار مرات
نصمم على الايد نعيد الديزاين وبدنا طبعا
بعد ما نجهز السياره بدنا نضطر نشوف
الامكان
نحطها فيه
[موسيقى]
مين اللي بيهتم اكثر اشي بالسيارات
القديمه الناس الكبيره الكبار بالسن ليش
لانهم عاشوا فتره عرفوا شو صار الهلمان
الموريس
المرسيدس عشوها وطلعوا فيها هلا في الجيل
الجديد طبعا ما بهتم بقول لك انا شو بدي
بالسياره هاي بالنسبه الي خرده بالنسبه له
انا بالنسبه الي اي كنز يعني زي الارض كل
سنه برتفع ترتفع قيمتها
كمان عندي قيمه السياره معنويا يعني اكثر
سياره بعتز فيها هي السياره 190 الخمسه
وستين عشان الوالد يعني اخذه فيها رحمه
الله عليه بيت اطلعوا فيها وفيها ذكريات
كتير يعني هاي السياره اكثر سياره بعتز
فيها دائما بالذات ممكن هدول ابيتهم برا
بالشتاء انا ما في موقع هديك صار مستحيل
الا دائما جوا يعني مكان مغلق
هذا الباص وعيد تصنيعه بالالفين 2015 لل
طبعا مثلوا في فيلم
اجزاءه معظم الاجزاء
يعني اصليه قديمه زي الاضواء
تبعون الجيش البريطاني
الموتور والاجزاء تبعته تبعون تراكبه فورد
قديم
انا بخصوص التصميم الداخلي بالنسبه
لتشغيل
ونشغل من هون
يدوي الساعات كلها ساعات قديمه ايام الجيش
البريطاني
الكبسات كلها طبعا قديمه
الغماز
غماز بعطيك بتعطي اشاره لانه زمان بعد
تجاوز عن الشمال في زمور الحرب العالميه
الثانيه هذا كانوا يستخدموا للحروب بس
طبعا في مشكله بدها تعديل مانويل
طبعا المساحات يدويات زمان ما كان في
الحالات الطوارئ طبعا لا سمح الله اذا
واحد بيطلع للامير جنسي بيكسر القزاز من
هون
طبعا اهم اشي اهم اشي بالباص الشهاده
شاركت باصات الرمله الليد المحدوده على
راس مالها طبعا بالجنيه فلسطيني
والسنه طبعا موجوده هون
[موسيقى]
عم بتامل بالمستقبل حلم انه يكون يعني
بفلسطين انه معرض للسيارات هدول عشان ما
يضيعوا
[موسيقى]